this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] uncle
joey here the joint is brought to you by
manscape listen they're starting a
movement over at manscape they want
everybody to take care of themselves and
with spring break approaching listen you
got to have your nuts tip top magoo some
women like thor guys some prefer big
butts
but no one prefers their men with
[__] smelly unkept [__] rat holes
that's why our friends at manscape
developed a new and improved lawnmower
4.0 to keep the weeds out of your
[__] crotch garden before you head
out to spring trip make sure you're
groomed from ball to tip join the
manscape movement by going to
manscape.com
code diaz d-i-a-z for 20 off and free
shipping get your day started by
trimming those [__] bat hairs with
the waterproof lawnmower 0.4.0 clear
your hose and smell the spring air with
the [__] weed whacker i love it where
is it it's around here somewhere i
always clean up my nose and also clean
up that [__] old nut sack like mine
with crop preserver and crop reviver
[__] tremendous and then you finish
off grooming with the plow 2.0 a little
razor you get a little [__] shave on
your face because if you're using
lawnmower for 4.0 on your nut sack and
your face you're doing it wrong boys
verbat listen to me get 20 off and free
shipping by going to manscape.com
and press code diaz d-i-a-z that's 20
percent off and free shipping at
manscape.com
code diaz listen manscape
for when you want to be caught with your
pants around your [__] ankles trim
that bush and get ready for spring break
20 off and free [__] worldwide
shipping
with code diaz at
the manscape.com is also brought to you
by cbd lion
listen when it comes to cbd the best now
what i've been doing is i found out from
somebody if you take
one drop of tbd under your tongue before
you work out you're gonna go through it
like a [__] savage i did a workout
with it this morning i felt a lot better
before and a lot better after it so add
that to your workout routine cbd lion is
number one
go to cbdline.com and read the third
party lab results
they will blow your [__] mind whether
it's the kinesiology tape the cream or
the delta nine gummies which are [__]
tremendous and i'm giving you
15 percent off for 20 off take a chance
go to cbd line pressing code joey your
joint and get 20 off and get on that
delta 9. they're worth their [__]
weight in gold again
cbd lion
dot tom
code joey read the third party lab
results and get some cbd and put one of
those cotton balls up your ass with cbd
you'll be jumping up and down for days
and now without further ado
here comes the joint [__] suckers uncle
joey's ready for you on a wednesday
morning
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__] i
dream a genie with a 10-foot weenie you
know what i'm saying it's wednesday
[__] get your [__] together it's
a beautiful [__] day to be alive i'm
feeling great
i'm sorry about the podcast i'm not i'm
not even [__] sorry i just had to
tell you how i feel that's it listen man
ever since i moved that
i left this dude alone it's like you're
dealing with a [__] [__]
but as usual people get [__] froggy
when the [__] king is away so now i
gotta come back and reclaim my
[__] throne you understand me
and we're working on it [__] but
it's great it's wednesday i'm feeling
good i had a great [__] week i don't
know if you guys got to watch
the uh show on hbo came on monday night
with john bernthal we were supposed to
he was supposed to be a guest today we
got rudy instead but we'll have bernthal
on next week to talk about uh we own the
city you watch it mike
not bad the first episode was kind of
[__] slow but john was great the
characters were great
you know i like that wire writing i like
all that [__] ghetto that i live for
that stuff it's great it's uh yeah they
always get going like the third episode
but hopefully we'll have john uh next
week i got rudy today rudy's one of my
favorite [__] people guys ever since
i've
met him
uh he's always been like an older uncle
like i i can ask him advice on anything
because
music comedy entertainment it all goes
hand in [__] hand a comedian is a
failed musician
and a musician is a comedian who was
[__] smart you know i'm saying that
he said [__] going on the road with no
guitar i got to protect myself and [__]
in case will smith wants to come up here
some [__] but all jokes aside no
i've had great talks of rudy we talk
about you know just the business and how
he sees it how i see it
you know
i started taking some guitar lessons
from and it's [__] crazy
like compared to my teacher that i was
paying 40 bucks
rudy was
30 times better
and it's so weird when you get a lesson
from somebody who he's a [__] legend
guys i mean
white snake you know it's just so many
[__] things but he's not a legend
because of his bass playing i'll tell
you that much he's a legend because he's
a good [__] guy man and uh
he just feels you know if if you're
smart and you're a young musician
i would follow rudy
he gives some great [__] advice he's
not a a partier he's not a heavy metal
banger you know
it's so funny when you meet people what
you
portray them to be like uh who's the
crazy guy i like the guy that does all
the ozzy osbourne [__] you know he does
he's got his own band
[__] crazy dude with a beard
you know
zack wilde you know zach wilde i love
zach wild but you know what i love about
zach wilde i love everything i hear
about
i love that when zach goes on tour he
goes on tour there ain't no showering
there ain't no shaving
you're just gonna be a [__] rough
neck and stink i love all that [__] but
then when he's home he's a dad he shaves
the beard he's at his kid's softball
game you know these are like split
you have to have like a split life in
this and you have to be cool with it if
not you how many times i was sitting
there eating dinner with
mercy and my wife and we're talking
about like you know
stupid kid [__] and before that was
saying prayers and while she's saying
prayers i'm like i gotta go down to the
store in an hour
and unleash a beret of [__] curses
racial epithets and all this [__] this
is this is double life nobody believes
this [__] like i'm sitting here saying
prayers with my hands up like a half a
[__] and everything and then now i'm
gonna be at the comedy store yelling and
screaming talking about sucking my dick
guys it's not normal but
you know you you you [__] figure it
out i couldn't imagine
being like for me
i would love to be like in a band and
have my kids and go fishing and [__] and
then tuesday night you show up in
philadelphia you're on stage with led
zepplin with guns and
you know you look over your shoulder and
there's [__] john bonham [__]
playing the [__] out of the drums
drinking jack daniels and [__] people
throwing your joints underwear as a fly
and you're like i can't wait
to get back to freehold to that softball
game on [__] saturday this is
craziness it's it's
it's insanely when you mix the two like
i learned from joe rogan because he
already had daughters and he had a
stepdaughter and i'm like how the [__]
do you do it you go out you be crazy you
smoke dope then you gotta go home and
face these [__] kids let me tell you
dog i try my hardest not to smoke around
my kid but i i try even harder
not to be stoned about it because i
don't know what the [__] she's talking
about when i'm sober so can you ima rick
dukeman one of my [__] idols had a
great joke that he had to stop smoking
dope when he had his kids
because
his kids were asking the creepy
questions while he was stoned like that
how come you drink grape juice it goes
in purple but it comes out yellow and he
would go uh let me you got to get back
to me and that's one of my favorite
[__] jokes from rick duke and rest
his soul
but
it's uh it's it's really [__] hard
guys and that's what i was having a hard
time with when i got back here
i was like what the [__] am i doing my
life i felt like i was in the mafia like
every night i'm having dinner with a
nice girl and another nice woman and
then i gotta go kill somebody i gotta go
shoot somebody in the [__] head and
then come back like nothing happened
like i would go to the store on a
tuesday night there's kate quigley would
be telling me run there's a check who
wants to suck your dick in the back and
i would get out you know after i would
do one show and then smoke a blunt and
then they give you a box of abx edibles
and then you go to the original room and
do another set and then i gotta go home
and walk in it's like hi and my
daughter's daddy we watched harry potter
and [__] he ate the [__] or
whatever the [__] they do on harry
potter how do you think i don't know
what she's talking about it's like i
just came from the store where some
woman was telling [__] my friend she
wanted to suck my dick i had to run out
and i come home to [__] harry potter
and disney movies and and kanto and [__]
it's tough but guess what i'm getting
ready to go live that [__] life again
because
it's fun
it's fun to have an alter ego
it's it's it's
amazing that i say those things on stage
on the podcast and people judge you
and they put you in a capsule they don't
know that you read a book to your
daughter every night they don't know
that
you know
you save birds i don't say birds i'm
just saying you know they don't know
what you're really about it's really
funny when people are like hey what are
you out doing drugs tonight no it's
sunday night i'm home watching winning
time with the [__] lakers why would i
want to be out tonight doing [__]
drugs i got something you know it's
it's just weird what people think of you
what they assume your life is like like
people always thought i had 20 people in
the green room
i don't want 20 people in the [__]
rainbow
you think i want chicks back there naked
i'm a married [__] man i like felicia
i like the emcee
they both smoke whoever don't want to be
in there they better be able to [__]
smoke one embassy told me i'm allergic
to thc lucy you ain't working this
weekend because there's gonna be a lot
of reefer in this [__] green room
edibles and thc dust and you know
when it's a lifestyle guys and you gotta
get into it and you know what i missed
it for a long time i missed
miss rock and roll
that's what i [__] miss guys and i
was scared
to rock and roll you have to be
you have to be today who's not going to
be there with a camera who's going to
[__] you know are you going to say a
[__] some word and people gonna tape
it and take you to f who the [__] knows
but you know what you just gotta go out
there and not give a [__] it's like
somebody telling you i don't want to go
to
i don't want to go to jiu jitsu because
i might break a bone i don't want to be
a boxer
because i might get brain damage if you
think about that [__] then you're gonna
get brain damage you probably got brain
damage already thinking that way
if you're gonna think that way but you
have to go up on stage going i don't
give a [__]
i don't give a [__] what they think and
especially me now i don't listen i'm not
going for no netflix special
i could care less if they like me or
they don't [__] like me i'm not going
for no nothing
i am going for an audition for tom
carvel tomorrow and you guys know i'm
excited about that [__]
i've lived to [__] i live for carvel to
have the opportunity unless i'm gonna
put the audition on tape there's
somebody on that movie that doesn't like
me
i can't even tell you who it is but last
time i put an audition in for a movie
that i took that the guy didn't like me
it was uh
a grudge match
and then i realized the director was the
one that
sent in the [__] email for me so you
never know when you get those type of
auditions at first i was like oh this
[__] is involved with this movie
knowing you know what that means and the
audition is just a page and a half so i
could learn that an hour and i could
just blast it i'll [__] read it first
then i'll put the yellow on it to mark
it and then i'll put my little things
then i smoke a joint and revisit it
that's how you [__] nail an audition
i got my little list i read through the
list to mark all this stuff so the
character has
a [__] history
and tomorrow morning like at 10 i have
my wife set up the little camera pool
the teleprompter and i'll drop some
[__] knowledge and hopefully i'll be
tom carvel listen the chances are slim
but [__] it you gotta go freak
[__] i preach this [__] you gotta
go for if you're walking on ice you
might as well dance and guess what it's
all over it's time for you to [__] go
for it that's it
yeah that's it's time for me to go for
it guys i've been sitting here long
enough
[__] going to softball games and
meeting parents it's time for me to go
on the road and tell you [__]
what i really think and that's plain and
[__] simple do not forget
it's sold out but they might let some
tickets loose i'm on hari's storytellers
show next monday night at the village
underground new york city eight o'clock
i don't know what time i'm going up
i'm just gonna go there tell a story and
[__] come home smoke a joint and see
the boys who's better than uncle joey
nobody [__] up this because now i got a
taste of blood and i'm ready for these
[__] now without further ado
the great rudy sarzo i hope you enjoy
this
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
i got sunburn
i got everything last weekend
it must have been 2 000 [__] degrees
in jersey on the baseball field
oh man awesome brother great to see you
so
it's blessing i'm really blessed it's
all good life is good no complaints
how's mama you know oh she's a man what
what a blessing to have her home with us
and uh
it was uh you know rebecca she she
instigated the whole thing that's that's
my wife you know i mean for for the
listeners you know
people watching this your my wife's name
is rebecca and she you know she was kind
of like yeah listen let's get her home
now because you know we were there
that theory was covered you know that
was kind of tough you know traveling and
almost impossible and the risk and and
and she was living in miami by herself
and she she didn't want to you know get
the shots and be all by herself and
something happened and so
as soon as we brought her here
to los angeles you know to live with us
and
and that uh right off the plane to get
her first vaccine for covet you know
so it's so good it's so good it's a it's
it's like uh
she's brought so much joy and and and
blessings to our home and yeah
we're having fun
actually you know rudy when you told me
you were bringing your mom
you know my sister died in cuba
like a month and a half ago maybe oh
sorry he couldn't really do anything i
couldn't really do anything you know the
situation i could call it yeah
yeah and it took me four days to get a
[__] calling card
i couldn't even get a calling card to
call and uh
you know it was weird but
thinking i was sad and at the same time
i was happy because now she's with my
mother which is what my mother always
wanted yeah
following a couple weeks rudy started
[__] me a little bit
i was watching uh some show winning time
the lakers on hbo and his mother sends
him off and i'm like i never had that
like i never had a mom sending you off
to [__] colorado or l.a or
before you go do a show or something and
you know
it was really weird because when my
mother died i swept it under the carpet
like i didn't deal with it immediately i
couldn't i was too young
i was involved with [__] and music and
concerts so i didn't have a chance to
really process it
so for some weird reason in my mind rudy
i always thought
as crazy as it sounds and i would see
her again
you know and it didn't dawn on me
40 [__] years later that i'm not
gonna [__] see it this was just a
pipe dream
i was saying to me so if any of the
listeners are [__]
the watchers whatever take one thing for
granted when your mom or your dad dies
your world
sucks dick
i'm telling you from me even 40 years
later she never got to see my
accomplishments
she never got to see that i could do
this or i could do that
so you got to be good to your moms and
i'm not saying this because next month
is mother's day or nothing i'm saying
this this is general you have to towards
the end
you want to be there with them you want
to eat i don't care if it's for that
last month to bring them in your house
so they see what you're about and you
you could see what they're about but now
i i resp i give you so much respect rudy
just for you being you
now for bringing your mom into the mix
you know 90 years old this is it these
are your golden years i mean what are
you [__] 65
this is it
this is the time you want to be with
[__] mom and i know they're a pain in
the ass they don't hear and you know but
you got to drive them to bingo you gotta
you know keep them involved take them
out take them to a bar let them have a
glass of wine you know mom did it for us
what should you do for your [__] mom
tell me i know well i go to therapy
because of my mom because you're a
[__] punk [__]
because you're a punk [__] tony
soprano too you don't go into psychiatry
and tell them that your mom your mom is
the goods and yeah there's great moms
there's good moms and there's some that
are bad but every mom comes around
the same way a dad comes around so i'm
very proud of you rudy and i i think i
can't imagine
the fulfillment you must feel
oh yeah i mean every night uh you know
she goes from our living room we have
dinner
and it's funny because
when i every time i i watch her in her
favorite chair because you know she's on
a walker so she's got to pick the
furniture that she feels comfortable
sitting in so she found this chair in
the living room
and that's kind of like her throne
we call it la reina because she was she
was born the same day the same year as
as queen elizabeth so she's just
celebrated her 96 just like the queen
did and if you add on top of that my
wife
was born the same day same year as
princess diana
i don't know what that means but that is
a fact so it's a message from the
english people you know what i'm saying
so
so getting back to my mom sitting there
so we got her you know really nice tv
dinner tray
you know so she sits there watching and
this is our ritual every day we watch
the family feud
and even though she's you know because
she's living in miami she really didn't
have the need to learn english now she
does and i mean she's got a purpose now
okay i learn english because i can talk
to my daughter-in-law
my wife and my wife is doing the same
thing she's learning spanish and i'm
like really impressed how fast she's
picking everything up because she wants
to now there's a purpose there's a
there's a person that speaks spanish
besides me in the house that she needs
to communicate with and and it's really
so so
so sweet to to walk in the room and my
wife has uh a an app on her phone and my
mom has an app in the phone and they
translate
what they wanna say to each other
it's a [__] it's a new adventure in
your life it is on top of many other
adventures now you're just
doing your thing required right my
apologies to you my my night got [__]
up that night
there was a there was a sleepover that's
how i got clearance that i believe i
love it love it the girl's gonna do a
sleepover and that afternoon the guy
the dad who was gonna watch him got
called into work in new york because
he's a a sanitation like executive
so he got called and he called me he's
like we're gonna cancel i go you know
what you can't get my daughter wouldn't
shut the [__] up about it all week and
the other kids
so i went over there and sat with them
until like [__] nine o'clock to the
moms got home because the moms are going
out and they didn't know what the right
hand the left hand was doing
but i'll catch you on the way back
either in pa oh yeah
jimmy said you were great he sent me a
video of the bass solo
[__] rudy up there doing his thing
looking like a [__] kid at the
palladium 40 years back oh yeah oh yeah
it's a it's weird because it's a state
of mind you know
and i
during this coven you know shut down i
say you know what i'm just gonna like
try to learn as much stuff as
interest special interest and one of
them was music i mean it's like
something you know it's like
did you ever question yourself like
what you do why do i do what i do what's
the meaning of yeah every goddamn thing
you know so so for me to be a musician
and it's not you know because growing up
as a kid i wanted to be a lot of things
i wanted to be a baseball player i
wanted to be a movie director but once i
got that
card handed to me and said okay this is
the card you're gonna play you're gonna
be a musician this is it
you know these are the cards that you
got so you know this is your hand in
life you know and i'm going like you
know there's got to be a reason there's
got to be a purpose for me doing this i
mean it's not just me getting up there
and playing a bunch of songs so this is
even before i i got back with quiet riot
you know frankie was still alive you
know and all of that so
and
so i you know i i went on the internet
start you know getting as much knowledge
and information going to different
websites saying okay i like this i don't
like that i like this i want to hear
more
and one thing came to the other so i
just started basically it came down
to quantum physics with me
and what really attracts me about
quantum physics is that first of all i
understand it not necessarily all of it
but the essence of it you know and to
actually
watch
scientists people who are way more
educated that i will ever be in my life
actually say yes there is a higher power
there is the highest power
a creator
and it it
the source and we are all a source of
that and this is
this is stuff that they do in the lab
they experiment this and they find
the smallest small small smallest
quantity you know they go down to
photons you know they go down into like
molecules and they split them splitting
of the atom there's more into the once
you split the atom it splits into
different parts it's more inside of it
and just like you go
higher you can go
you know positive negative or it could
be the same thing this really you know
what device poses a negative is that
middle line that neutral neutral right
and you go in either directions you're
going in the same thing you're just
getting more of the opposite you know
and
and so i started studying and to
actually hear
scientists these are people who are like
they start out you know debunking the
existence of a higher power and years
ago what was popular was to think that
we live in a chaotic
universe
the whole thing this is all by accident
no this is not by accident
this is this is purely
there's a purpose and there's law
and there's the laws of nature the laws
of the universe the laws of the creation
the creator and the fact
that
what science is leaning towards is the
fact that you me everybody else has ever
existed
this is a hologram
what we experience
we're just making this thing up
and it's according to our consciousness
our belief system that things turn
into they manifest themselves
i've read about that
i read about that years ago i had to
smoke like 22 joints while i was reading
it
i can't remember the name of it
but it's that the images we see are only
in our mind mike doesn't see the same
images that i see
it's the same images molecules are
bumping up against each other and you
just don't see it it's just a
thing of our mind it's our own movie
made from our mind our life i guess
that's what they say it makes sense to
me a little bit
the other half i'm [__] up on so i'm
not a psychiatrist
and i'm not a [__] smart guy you know
what i'm saying but it's uh
it's really weird but this pandemic made
people think a lot
you know made people think a lot
others have made them so scared that
they refused to think
and they just kept going like a chicken
without a head on i'm seeing a lot of
the results from that
i'm seeing the way the pandemic affected
people mental health you know mental
health [__] through the roof
you see it
people may not know they're experiencing
it
they're trying harder they're
overcompensating
you know there's been so many changes we
can't keep up with them this has been a
tough time for the country
and i'll tell you really i didn't know
how bad the clinton the country
needed entertainment
um i just heard something yesterday
where the stones had the number one tour
of last year and they did like eight
[__] shows
they did like 115 billion [__]
dollars those guys and every concert now
this summer i mean
the the concert is a [__]
everybody's out from quiet riot to elton
john to [__] everybody's doing a
mystery tour
so it's like the hardest you know
people are going to [__] shows man
that's what i'm trying to say people are
going to comedy shows
people are going out because they never
want to feel the way they did for those
[__] two years again
so people are really overcompensating
planes are packed
you know vacation
packages are packed
i mean we finally got a house uh the
last week of august in [__]
north carolina i'm going down there with
eight of the families and the kids and
the boat and the [__] helicopter
i don't know how the [__] i do i gotta
drive eight hours i don't know how the
[__] i'm gonna do it but
we'll burn that bridge when we get to it
you know how much longer do you have
left on the tour routes
oh this is open-ended open-ended it's as
long as people keep showing up you know
because you have
you have a
you you make such a
great point that's saying that people
want to be entertained
and i tell you what what you know i i
heard you say that and what triggered in
my mind was
you know i just like you i'm also an
entertainer so
i i i study
uh
the meaning of what of what i do to
contribute to
when people gather to come or see your
show
what am i offering to them for their
money and their time
they made the effort to be there they're
there so now it's my responsibility my
responsibility to deliver
whatever they came for and then some
because once you give them that extra
they keep coming for more
you know what i mean you just don't say
okay
you pay so much for a tick and i'm gonna
give you a hundred dollars worth of
entertainment from me no it's like you
give them everything you got and then
you try to find that extra bit and say
here
thank you so much
for coming here because i've been a fan
longer than i've been a professional
musician so i i know of the sacrifices
that fans make
like myself you know trying to get
together three dollars and 50 cents to
go and see led zeppelin play at the
exploratorium in in fort lauderdale you
don't know that you know and everything
it starts like a week before you prepare
yourself and you listen to the music you
get pumped up on your friends you know
somehow you get a hold of a led zeppelin
shirt somewhere in a
in one of the x stores you know and and
i'm talking this in the 60 and the 70s
so
merchandise was very very limited back
then you know there was usually bootleg
stuff you know and and then you make it
to the show and it becomes a an
unforgettable experience that i'm still
talking about it with you 50 years later
it's crazy because
i charge 25 for my tickets
30 on a friday and saturday even though
the agent's like it's new york you could
chuck no
30.
i'm not when i do a podcast and you tell
me you don't like to podcast that
i don't give a [__] it's an hour we talk
three hours we talk we try to
communicate the best we can when you
tell me
i did a role in the movie and you didn't
like how i acted that's fine too i could
tolerate that when you tell me you came
to the comedy store to see me on a
tuesday
and you say you didn't like my set i
could deal with that the only thing i
can't deal with is bombing on the road i
got a real
[__] thing
about people coming to see me and my
performance on the road
you know i tell people all the time when
you're a gambler you don't remember the
big things you won you remember the [__]
you lost
you know with with the musicians you
remember the bad shows you know you
your base was off who the [__] knows
your cat died
oh it's a thousand variables when you
have four people
putting a band together when you go to
see a concert and that concert is
tremendous
you gotta thank your lucky stars because
four people were on that night at the
same [__] time you were the yankees
that night
you were the yankees you know what i'm
saying some nights the singer's got a
sore throat his chick gave him vd you
know he's not going to go out there
and sling dick like usual for me when it
came that's why i like the proportion
that's why
i didn't want to go on the road i didn't
want to be guns and roses every night i
think that you need just like when you
need to recuperate from weights when you
lift weights
they tell you not to lift weights more
than four days a week you got to recover
you got to recover also
so i always respected that because i
knew the more spaghetti i threw on the
wall the more chances i got the bomb
so during the week i don't want to be
out i want to be at little comedy clubs
trying new [__] out because if i'm on a
bomb i'm going to bomb there i don't
want to bomb i mean i looked at
percentages
that's how crazy i took it down to
i took it down to percentages
i want to do great in nine out of ten
shows i want to do great in 10 out of 10
shows
but i know it's not a possibility it's
nothing to do with me it could be the
microphone the the the sound coming it
doesn't sound right but for the most
part it's on me but i know i could give
you
nine out of ten i wanted to give you
immaculate performances
not just that i was good you know i want
i want you if you go i thought that
[__] was gonna have a heart
attack
i did my job
like i did if my face gets red like it
did two weeks ago
and you know it was the first time i was
on stage in a year so if my face gets
red i got a little anger issue to me
that night
you're on top you're winning you got it
you know that's what i want but i always
knew that the percentages
if i go out seven nights a week in a row
i'm gonna bomb two of those nights
i'm five and i'm gonna try to charge you
big money i'd rather charge you 20 bucks
you come to the store you see 20 people
and if i bomb it's okay
i just want my percentages to be up on
the weekend
those four shows have to be tremendous
and again
i know those five shows aren't gonna be
great they're gonna be four out of five
when i do thursday and then two saturday
so i'll add one on thursday that gives
me six shows
and i'll bomb one of those shows out of
the six not bomb
i don't bomb anymore i just have a bad
set that's how i did my [__] percentages
i have so much respect for what you do
because just to get up there on stage
all by yourself not with the bands
not with the band not with three other
four other guys but just on your own you
are the show
you know like if it not that i
that i can tell you that i ever phone it
in but you know [__] happens [__]
happens on the road you know and
sometimes your equipment is not working
or you know properly or whatever or you
get the flu i've gotten the flu and i've
gone on stage i have to sit down middle
of the show because i can't take it
anymore
i sit on the drum riser i tell you what
duluth minnesota
1988 uh yeah no no no actually in 1980 i
tell you guys
yeah you know so i i remember all this
stuff right okay so
so what
with me now
is that
it's it's it's a whole different level i
the purpose of me going on stage going
on the road is to celebrate the legacy
of quiet riot you know this year 40th
anniversary of
recording mental health the album
and i go you know prior to that in 1978
with randy rhodes may join in the band
so next year is going to be
45 years since first time i played with
quiet riot you know and and my
and and and to celebrate the memory of
frankie benelli kevin dubrow and randy
rhodes that's my mission i step out that
door
when i go on the road like i will got
willing this friday step out the door
and i now i know you know it's not about
whoa it's it's 4 30 in the morning i
gotta catch an uber to go to uh the
airport no no no it's now it's like wow
i get to do this
you know i get to celebrate
i got a mission now
and for in some way some reason for me
it's
going deeper
deeper because it's like no no no no
this is not just me getting up there on
playing stage anymore this is this is
about
the consciousness the consciousness that
brought me
to quiet riot in the 70s four guys
you know three of the guys well since
there were you know uh kevin and randy
and drew forsyth uh the drummer they
were born and raised in
in that area in the los angeles area me
i'm from cuba you know i met all the way
down to l.a so i had some different you
know circumstances i was not living at
home
i was not you know doing things in my my
my hometown no i was like the guy who
was on survival mode all the time trying
to like stay be able to stay in the band
because i'm not gonna have to go back to
miami or whatever or new jersey you know
this this was it i already done that
about three times prior to 1978. i had
left l.a because i kept running out of
money so on this time that was the last
time you know and so it was like all we
were focused we're gonna make it we're
gonna get a record deal this is going to
be a great band because that's what i
saw when i first saw choir riot as a guy
me walking into the starwood
i saw this band on stage and i got it i
said these guys they have the vision
they know where they're going and and if
they keep going they will get there
and
so then again about a year later i'm in
the band so i understood that i knew
what i was getting myself into and it
was a collective
consciousness
you know that we had and that was 45
years ago
next year so it's 44 years this year and
and and
it means everything to me you know i've
heard of guys who like
you know they have they have like their
their favorite memories making music was
in the garage because all of the guys
they were all about the same thing we
just you know we're happy here in this
garage we're making music it had nothing
to do with anything outside of that of
that room
right everything that would that would
that they all
lived for existed there in a combination
of four or five guys or girls right
and
that band
broke up in 1979 that garage band and it
was not a garage band because you know
we were playing around town and stuff
like that but it was basically that that
that's what i mean is the belief system
of a garage band we're going to make it
right so then randy goes over and joined
ozzie later on i joined ozzie randy dies
and
and ten years ago i mean 40 years ago
this year
i walk into a room to record one song as
a tribute
to the memory of randy rhodes a song
called thunderbird that i used to play
with kevin dubrow
while i was playing with him in his band
dubrow which is
when choir riot broke up that's what he
put together and i was living with kevin
so i was trying to subsidize my
my my expensive you know that i was
living with him when i was paying rent
so i would play with him
and
i that's one of the songs that i played
that so i knew so i went back in there
with
you know to record just one song and
that song led me
to leave ozzy one of the biggest bands
in the world and they were treating me
fantastic they were they were tremendous
with me they were generous and kind
and to leave that because i have lost my
family when i my country my choir
consciousness when i when randy died it
wasn't there anymore
it wasn't
you know
i mean if you look at the stage during
while randy was in in aussie and i was
there
it was two guys from choir riot on each
side of asi
two guys that have been
a couple of years earlier
told that we were dinosaurs
that we were never gonna make it by the
los angeles record companies
and here we are playing with ozzy and
randy had already recorded these two
amazing
and composed records
blizzard of oz and diary of amendment
here we are and i'm going like yes
and of all the things is you know randy
and i
we came from from basically the same
environment
you know i grew up in the caribbean
south florida
everything was the beach sunny
same thing with with randy it was all
about living in l.a sunny l.a you know
you want to go to the beach you just go
down to the beach any month of the year
whereas ozzie was raised
in the rubble of the blitzkrieg
he was born like you know two or three
years after world war ii ended and as a
child as a baby he was going to these
lots in his neighborhood
that was just rubble
from all the bombs being dropped by the
nazis you know in birmingham an
industrial setting
i mean nowhere else could music like
black sabbath originated
that was it that was the soundtrack of
the city of that time
blacks out with music so you know you
have like different consciousness ozzy
very dark then you have randy me
growing up and and you know in sunny
environments you know completely
different so once randy was gone it was
all dark that's all that's all i felt
darkness not not that they are
you know ozzy sharon or tommy whoever
you know that we happen to be traveling
together never they're bad people or
dark people
but that was the
the spirit this is where they where they
came from
not necessarily tommy because he came
from
he was born in texas and raising our you
know he lived in arkansas when he was
playing with the with black oak and all
of that but but definitely ozzy ozzy
very very gloomy
especially after randy passed away
obviously you know
you know it's crazy
when i first contacted you a couple
weeks ago it was to do a podcast about
randy 40 years later remembering
something
and then [__] 10 days later maybe
five days later taylor dies
i didn't call you for a few days and
i'll tell you why because
taylor's death
reminded me a lot of randy's there
when i see taylor hawkins smiling that's
the last [__] i thought was
gonna die ever
ever him and uh
twinkle toes on the guitar they're
always smiling they're the happiest
people in the [__] world uh
the guy that does the really good
barbecue what's his name
you know when he died i i for a couple
days i mean and i didn't even come up a
quiet ri uh
a foo fighters tremendous fan i'm just a
[__] fan of them and i like what they
do
but it felt like randy
it felt a lot like randy because it's
the last
thing i expected to hear i expected to
hear you know
that ronnie whatever died in jail he's
getting old what's what's the [__]
porno guy that's getting charged with 78
rapes you know i expected to you know
somebody to break their leg but i never
saw
taylor hawkins dying yeah taylor hawkins
may be having an accident and breaking
his ankle like uh you know the singer
from guns and roses and he has to
perform on a stilt or some [__] but i
don't i i i never when i got when i
would listen bro i when i walked out of
that house on a friday night
and i got in my buddy's car in april
and also he goes here what happened
randy rhodes died i was done i didn't
know the man i didn't need to know the
man
but i was done for a few days that added
that just woke up
the pain that my mother left three years
earlier when she
that put me right back there and that's
what happens when somebody dies when
somebody close to me dies
it wakes up a sleeping [__] giant for
a few days the same thing happens with
taylor and i'm
you know i could see if i was like a big
tale of i mean i was a fan of his i
remember him with an alanis morris set
but
he was the last guy like randy
what was randy 20 years old or something
like that the last
26 years
26 he's a [__] baby guitar he was
about to take over the world with that
[__] guitar or him and [__] eddie
were going to have a blast like russia
and ukraine they were just going to
throw guitars at each other they were
just tremendous and
one day they just disappeared and that
was it
so when you talk about that like the
taylor thing i wanted to bring it up to
you because that's what it felt like
and i know to you it didn't feel like it
i'm not trying to
you know
i know you were tight with taylor and i
know you're the type of guy
that's very empathetic but randy was
randy to you and taylor's tailor but
it's still a death
it should affect you you should have a
reaction to it
absolutely i posted immediately
based on my experience with taylor i
never
saw him high and we were in events where
other people were high
you know public events part you know
like events you know like celebration
like you know
not just at people's home doing i mean
you know we went to a couple things for
example uh
uh one of them was uh sebastian bach
he throws a birthday party and there was
a bunch of people there and then there's
tailoring his
and he was a some sort of a disco team
and he's wearing disco clothes
and he's just like i don't even think i
saw him drinking
you know he's just hanging and
and
i jam with him
uh he had this side projects
uh
and
never i never saw him hide
i own anything
you know so
so
what i did see was somebody that was
incredibly driven every time i see his
footage of him performing and doing his
tribute to freddie mercury at wembley
stadium
and all that i see man this
this this man is very special plus
i used to i'm really good friends and i
play with sas jordan
and seth jordan is who discovered
taylor playing in a club in in south
southern california
locally from this area and then from
seth jordan's band i mean you know you
guys can watch
you know on youtube him playing with
jordan
and uh
then that's when sass took a break
as she tells me
and and atlantis morris said who somehow
they share some some sort of either
management or label or anything like
that she needed a band to promote her
new record
jack a little pill and that's where
taylor joined the band because they
basically took sas band and they put it
together and it's easier to do that you
know
and
so yeah i mean she spent a lot of time
with taylor and there was never ever any
any conversation regarding addiction or
or
drunk you know
being an alcoholic or anything like that
nothing you know
so is quiet right going to put on an app
we're working on it we're working on it
and i am
it's it's coming along beautifully and
i'm very very uh
very pleased you know i mean
i will be completely pleased once it's
done because right now when you're in
the process you really don't get to
enjoy it as much as once it's done once
it's done it's like okay let me hear it
now and it's like hearing it for the
first time
because you know you have to you have to
wear one hat one hat is the creator and
then
the the next hat is the spectator you're
watching this and you're listening to it
you go wow that's really cool and you
kind of like
i can do this i don't know if everybody
can do this but i can actually separate
myself from my creative self
to my
spectator
once you know watching or listening to
me perform you know then i can be
critical about it
that's uh
i'm [__] really happy for you rudy
you look great
i know that this is uh a pac
what do you call it a
[__] a passion of a a project of joy
right
the mission admission
of joy you know
are you doing a lot of the writing you
got other guys in the band
oh yeah
i mean
everybody contributes you know it's
really a bad ben effort uh you're all
out in l.a
no
no we're not but we are mastering
the technique of doing everything
because you know we get together on
when we when we tour
and then when we create when we get
creative see when you're on tour you
basically the way it's done now you know
with the schedule you got to get up at
four o'clock in the morning to be in the
lobby to catch a flight you know and
hold on
please pray to god that it that you
don't get delayed or or it doesn't get
cancelled so you can make it to the next
gig
so you're more focused on that not not
necessarily on the creative aspect of it
but more on the survival mode of
survival in this experience so you can
get to the next
the next gig and do it all over again
you know and uh so once one once we come
home i can actually put that creative
hat on
and i'm um i'm i'm very happy i'm very
very pleased with the with the way
things are are
shaping up
you're a [__] animal rudy and you're
an inspiration i've learned a lot
you're doing mine
from uh being around you
it's always a [__] pleasure i don't
know when i'm gonna make it back out to
california i'm trying
uh i called my agent yesterday i got
some [__] auditions again i got a
little hot you know and i got some
auditions i got one for tom carvel
i'm gonna play the [__] ice cream
mogul i hope
[__] that'll be me and [__]
don't be [__] laughing mike you know
i love tom carvel [__]
but uh rudy
uh let's stay in touch let me know when
you're coming this way i'll go see you
in hershey pennsylvania i'll go see you
in the bronx
i'll go to brooklyn or something
wherever you're going to be uh
that's it brother i love you to death
i'm happy all right
and i miss you i miss you i miss you i
miss you out here you know
yeah yeah yeah no listen
the clouds are parting and the blue sky
is starting to come up again in my life
it was uh it was a roller coaster there
for like a year but we're back you know
what i'm saying
wonderful wonderful wonderful to your
dad god bless you thank you
i love you
i love you thank you bye-bye
cheech what's happening i hope you
enjoyed rudy sarzo as much as i do the
guy drops knowledge
he's uh i think close to 70 and he's
still out there doing it that's not an
inspiration for me i just got to do it
on my own [__] terms [__] these
agents [__] everybody it's back to joey
diaz time [__] i love you at all
my heart
thank you for watching both podcasts
this week thank you for having our back
thank you for having our patreon
we love you to death and we'll see you
monday morning
may 2nd god damn this month is going the
rent is due [__] so don't be spending
at the [__] chinese restaurant
tonight i love your [__] up to stay
black
and i'll see you next monday tip top
[__] magoo jack
all right you [__] savages
thank you very much for supporting the
podcast thank you for loving rudy rudy's
a [__] gentleman i want to thank rudy
i want to thank you guys
but i also want to thank manscape listen
like i told you in the beginning spring
break's here you want to look your best
you want your dick sucked you're going
to walk around with that [__] wolf
man hanging around your nut sack listen
women like dog guys
some like butts but no no woman wants a
[__] guy with smelly [__] nuts
that's where the manscape movement comes
in they develop their own lawnmower 4.0
to keep the weeds out of your [__]
crotch hell that's down there before you
head out for spring break or tonight or
any other [__] night of the week make
sure you groom from ball to tip you want
to leave a good impression you want them
to call back how they gonna call you
back if you're stick if your dick stinks
like newark join the manscape movement
by going to manscape.com
code diaz for 20 off and free shipping
get your day started by trimming your
[__] wayward balls with the lawnmower
4.0 they also got the the body wash and
the [__] two two-in-one shampoo
they got the lip balm plus you're gonna
clear your hose with the [__] weed
whacker that's for your nose and your
ears and then you're gonna spruce up
your nut sac with the crop preserve and
the crop reviver
finish off grooming routine with the
plow 2.0 a razor makes your face like a
baby's ass listen to me if you're still
mowing your face with the lawnmower
and your balls and you're doing your
face afterward you're a [__]
disgusting animal even though i like to
go under my mustache then sniff the
razor anyway get 20 off free shipping by
going to manscape.com
pressing code diaz d-i-a-z
that's 20 off plus free shipping at
code manscape.com
manscape for when you want to get caught
with your pants around your ankles
also on the agenda cbd line when it
comes to cbd line they're the [__]
best
listen you got a bunch of people trying
to sell your cbd tell them what to sniff
your [__] nut sack you just manscape
[__]
anyway tell them all to suck your dick
you're with the lion cbd lion the best
cbd available on the market says who
says your uncle joey who lives off cbd
and he's breaking down like an old man
that he [__] is go to cbdlion.com
right now read the third-party lab
results
get yourself detention a basketball the
cream is tremendous but the delta nine
gummies are pushing a different [__]
perspective and i'm giving you 20 off
for your first order so go to cbd lion
order some delta nine gummies it's time
to see the devil and get your body back
into tip top shape i want to thank
manscape [__] cbd lion i want to
thank uh
who else was on here this week uh
[__] uh
you got better help on monday
you got blue chew i want to thank
fuckingstamps.com
and i want to thank you guys for [__]
always having my back i love you
[__] stay black have a great week
and i'll see you [__] may 2nd
monday tip top magoo
[Music]
you